George Orwell was an English
intellectual who died in 1950 and used
literature for the only reason it
ultimately really exists to try to
change the world for the better he was
in the deepest sense a political writer
someone who wanted art to help us grow
kind fairer wiser in 1946 a year after
the publication of his momentously
popular fable Animal Farm he wrote an
essay titled why I write which laid out
his approach with a characteristic
clarity what I wanted to do throughout
the past 10 years is to make political
writing into an art my starting point is
always a feeling of partisanship a sense
of injustice when I sit down to write a
book I don't say to myself I'm going to
produce a work of art I write it because
there is some lie I want to expose some
fact to which I want to draw attention
and my initial concern is to get a
hearing to understand why Orwell matters
we therefore have to understand what
this most political of writers loved and
what he hated what he was in rebellion
against and what he championed this is
what will give us the keys to
understanding his remarkable work and
painful yet deeply fulfilled life
Georgia will always hated the social
group of which he was despite everything
an exemplary member intellectuals from
an early age he wanted to be a writer
but George Orwell excelled at never
quite belonging he was born in 1903 in
India which was then part of the British
Empire to economically fragile civil
servant parents who fought for him to
have a classic upper-middle class
English upbringing and then hoped he
might become a doctor or a lawyer they
sent him to what turned out to be a
crippling mean-spirited English prep
school at the age of eight from where he
won a scholarship to Eton but he turned
against the values and spirit of the
English public school system he never
went to university and after stint as an
imperial policeman in Burma he settled
into the life of the odd robbing
literary intellectual
working in a hamster bookshop reviewing
other people's books and eventually
writing some of his own nevertheless
Orwell's disdain of intellectuals was a
constant he accused them of a range of
sins a lack of patriotism resentment of
money and physical vigor concealed
sexual frustration pretension and
dishonesty he knew it all from the
inside but all Wells greatness emerged
from the rider termination with which he
recognized and came to triumph against
such tendencies in himself the really
important fact about the English
intelligentsia he once wrote is their
severance from the common culture of the
country in left-wing circles it's always
felt that there's something slightly
disgraceful in being an Englishman and
that it's a duty to snigger at every
English institution from horse racing to
suet puddings Orwell's generation of
intellectuals which had witnessed the
First World War and the Great Depression
was obsessed with Airy abstract large
schemes to redeem humankind some were
fanatical communists others staunch
defenders of radical capitalism a few
admired the new authoritarian regimes of
Italy Spain and Germany and wanted
something similar to take hold in the
Anglophone sphere Orwell listened and
was for a time a little seduced but he
came gradually to champion something far
more radical the tastes opinions needs
an outlook of someone he called the
ordinary person a knowledge of ordinary
life came rather late to all well as a
typical product of an English public
school he was little exposed anyone
below his own social class a tendency
compounded by a naturally aloof bookish
and diffident manner a friend described
him age 25 as remarkably moth-eaten for
one his age but all well set out to make
up for his lack of knowledge and
gradually came to be the great defender
of what he repeatedly called ordinary
life
the life of people not especially
blessed with material goods people who
work in ordinary jobs who don't have
much of an education who won't achieve
greatness and yet nevertheless love care
for others work have fun raise children
and have large thoughts about the
deepest questions in ways that all well
thought as
specially admirable Orwell's journey
into ordinary life began in the spring
of 1928 when he left the privileges of
his class behind and went to work in a
series of menial service jobs in the
French and English capitals experiences
he was to recount in his book down and
out in Paris and London published in
1933 the book is filled with
affectionate portraits of life behind
stairs in hotels and restaurants and
revels in camaraderie humor and warmth
of an assortment of cleaners washer
uppers waiters chefs and the occasional
prostitute and [ __ ] it was a side of
life or well was further to investigate
in a book chronicling his journeys
around the industrial coal mining
country of northern England in a 1937
book titled the road to weaken peer
again without sentimentality or reverse
snobbery Orwell cast the generous
complex eye over the people he met and
concluded that the average pub in a coal
mining village contained more
intelligence and wisdom than the British
Cabinet or the high table of an Oxbridge
college or well especially liked the
lack of prudishness and hypocrisy among
the ordinary people he met one thing one
notices he writes if one looks directly
at the common people especially in the
big towns is that they are not
puritanical they are inveterate gamblers
drink as much beer as their wages will
permit a devoted to bawdy jokes and use
probably the Fowler's language in the
world then as now there was plenty of
information in the news about ordinary
people but all well understood that this
news tended to turn people into
abstractions and he saw it as the role
of his craft
literary journalism to flesh out the
human beings behind the statistics and
so correct the prejudice and casual
racism that circulated all around in an
essay written on a trip to Marrakech
Orwell wrote sarcastically but the
typically neo-colonial attitude of
travelers towards the local inhabitants
the people here have brown faces there
are so many of them are they really the
same flesh as yourself do they even have
names or are they merely a kind of
undifferentiated brown stuff about as
individual as bees or coral
insects all people who work with their
hands are partly invisible and the more
important the work they do for less
visible they are all wells love of the
ordinary inspired his curiosity about a
range of themes not often considered in
literature he thought about and wrote in
praise of comics and country walks
dancing and flowers
he wrote bravely in defense of English
cooking kippers Yorkshire pudding
Devonshire cream muffins and crumpets he
wrote and then asked where else other
than in English cooking do you see
potatoes roasted under the joint which
is far and away the best way of cooking
them were well wrote tenderly in defense
of Charles Dickens at a time when this
great writer was considered lowbrow and
too popular to win the esteem of
intellectuals in a great essay of 1946
politics in the English language Orwell
stood up against the prose typical of
intellectuals hi blown and full of long
fancy words and defended a simple almost
naive way of writing he outlined a list
of rules for how to write well which
included a complete ban on fancy words
like phenomenon categorical utilize
inexorable and veritable Orwell revealed
a hatred of foreign words like status
quo and deus ex machina and concluded
there is really no need for any of the
hundreds of foreign phrases now current
in English George Orwell is today
extremely famous for two books which
played a very small part in his life if
measured simply in terms of years he
wrote Animal Farm in 1945 when he was 42
and he published 1984 in 1949 when he
was 45 but he was dead by January 1950
at the age of only 46 in other words he
had just four short years being The Awl
well we know today nevertheless these
two books are anchored in deep thinking
that Orwell had done all his adult life
about how literature should be written
in an age of movies and mass
communication in short he knew that the
task of the writer was to ensure that
the most serious ideas should achieve
mass
popularity a double act which required
particular skill and intelligence animal
farm is a political tract about how
revolutions fall prey to counter
revolutions and turn their backs on
their original ideals it fairly maps out
the progress of the French Revolution
the European revolutions of 1848 and the
Russian Revolution of 1917 but described
like this no one outside of a few
academics would ever bother to read it
all Welles genius was to hit upon a form
the fable which would carry his story to
a mass audience and could be understood
as he put it by more or less anyone so
all well did would ESOP walt disney
level-10 and Beatrix Potter among many
others have done which is to tell a
story about humans via animals in the
process Orwell revealed the sins of
revolutionaries are not limited to
people involved in actual revolutions
indeed that it's a permanent human
possibility to believe one is guided by
high ideals and then go on to betray
them all every time a revolution now
goes wrong people bring up Animal Farm
and declare it to be ahead of its time
so prescient this is the genius of
Orwell's fable by cutting out all
contemporary human references or well
found a way to tell us about ourselves
for all time even for the future having
successfully reinvented the fable Orwell
in an astonishing burst of creativity
then reinvented the science fiction
novel as a boy he'd loved the novels of
HG Wells especially The Time Machine and
the War of the Worlds like Welles Orwell
seized upon trends in his own time and
tried to imagine how they might develop
over the long term his science-fiction
novel is set in airstrip one a place
once known as Great Britain but now a
province of the super state of Oceania
and locked in perpetual ideological
conflict with two other blocks Eurasia
and Eastasia like all great dystopian
novels Orwell's book was an attempt to
warn his own society about its own
alarming trends for example he could see
that what Kant
in either country is not so much
outright torture or clumsy covert
restrictions on free speech but a
lulling of the citizenry through
sophisticated entertainment and
empty-headed news reports all wrapped up
in a constant reference to freedom so in
1984 society is full of intriguing new
machines omnipresent screens which both
addicted and at the same time watch over
their citizens Julia the leading female
figure in the novel works in a
department of government known as mini
true which systematically distorts
access to information in highly subtle
ways to blind the citizenry to their
enslavement Julia operates a machine
that turns out porn novels alongside
films losing with sex rubbishy
newspapers containing almost nothing but
sport crime and astrology the people
however don't feel they are enslaved as
all well so well understood the really
clever and scary regimes of the modern
world aren't the obviously dictatorial
ones they are the apparently democratic
ones that give their citizens the
distinctive feeling that they are free
while in fact blinding them with
constant sexual titillation and
sentimental distractions George Orwell
had the wisdom to make himself
remarkably future-proof he was weary of
economic and political abstractions he
stuck close to the truths of ordinary
life the realities of sex food money
love and pleasure and he wrote with
total clarity about enduring eternal
themes in human nature he is perhaps the
most successful serious english-language
writer of the 20th century and gives us
the tools to continue to imagine what
writing should be in our own time
ultimately Orwell's message is the same
as the plea that he discerned in all of
Charles Dickens's books in the essay he
wrote on him namely that human beings
should behave better this as he pointed
out is either a terrific cliche or just
about the most important instruction in
the whole of life it was all Welles
genius to remind us that it is of course
very much the latter
you